hi so now it's uh the talk for python
bioinformatics by
Trend Hawk uh a little bit introvert
Trend trying Hulk has been work using
python for
over 13 years
and now he's working his he works in
biotech and develops software and
consult as part of his company where
true technology please welcome him for
his talk thanks
cool thanks uh can everybody hear me
okay
okay great uh we'll go yeah so uh very
excited to be here
um this is actually the first Pi Day to
Seattle I've been to since uh the one in
2015 so it's been like about eight years
since since then also it was on the uh
the Microsoft campus
um
so uh just kind of a quick background
and then we'll get into a couple things
um one so yeah uh like was mentioned I'm
a principal at a company called where
true Technologies uh we develop uh
software that sort of brings together uh
bioinformatics with uh SQL so uh for
folks who have worked in bioinformatics
in some some aspect you might know how
challenging it is and how uh specialized
a lot of the data formats are and so our
goal is to sort of elevate bioinformatic
data into the realm of SQL and then with
that hopefully you get a lot of the
benefits you get when working in the SQL
ecosystem uh before that I was sort of
software engineer data scientist at a
company called zymergin and Mammoth
biosciences primarily focused on what's
known in the sort of Industry as
Discovery tasks for example trying to
find a novel Gene novel enzymes that can
be used as Gene therapies so if folks
have heard of like cas9 trying to find
find enzymes like cas9 but might be
smaller or have more specificity or
other application other attributes that
make them beneficial
uh I'd be remiss to mention real quick
sort of what software that we developed
so like here's an example of some of the
software we build I actually haven't
heard much about Polaris here which I
was a bit surprising to me but um but
here's an example where we can use say
like Polaris to run queries on VCF files
uh oops or
um yeah use a tool called ductdb which I
also thought I would hear more about but
I I feel like I'm a little bit uh
um maybe a bit in a bubble sometimes but
but anyway so you can imagine like
running SQL on top of fast a files to
select them so that's sort of the the
tools that that we build
um okay so I want to talk or just to
briefly mention the outline
um uh one going to talk a little bit
about how python is used for the
productionization of bioinformatics jobs
in industry or in Academia a lot of the
jobs are you know some tasks that needs
to be run say run like Gene annotations
run some alignment call variants etc etc
and there's a lot of CLI tools that have
been developed to do this and so python
is quite often used as the glue to bring
those uh tools together say you run a
CLI tool get its output maybe you need
to push it to S3 right and so like
python might be responsible for running
the CLI and then also say interacting
with with S3
um
have to mention llms
um these are not sort of like chat GPT
but um they the same applications of
next token prediction uh apply except
the tokens in this case are say maybe
like the next nucleic acid or the next
amino acid in a protein sequence and so
um the the use cases are nascent you
know it's it's maybe kind of like
they're uh it is now where lots of
people are talking about it and and it
looks promising but to say it's had a
huge impact is probably getting a little
bit ahead of ahead of ourselves and then
finally the there's just like data
munging and so we'll talk a little bit
about how a couple examples of two
libraries one biopython which folks
might be familiar with if you've worked
in the area at all or another one called
Pi ranges which is a tool to facilitate
working with genomic ranges which is a
very common task
um okay so to um to talk about
informatic jobs a little bit and what
that entails
um so this is just going to be a bit of
a survey
um so a few things so one yeah so
bioinformatic jobs
um bioinformatics informatics jobs
um are often like these basically
computational tools developed in
Academia for the most part although as
um uh industry is adopting more of even
like the research side folks are
developing sort of Novel
um algorithms and novel bioinformatics
tools in-house which which probably
hadn't been done uh beforehand but a lot
of these tools again are coming coming
out of Academia like I mentioned um and
yeah biotech and then pharmaceutical
companies of of course
um
jobs is sort of like as amorphousive
term here as it is in all other uh
Industries where you know it might be
some algorithm that's being developed it
might be some statistical analysis or it
might just be some data processing where
you need to take a bunch of data over
here and move it over there nothing
nothing too special about that
um what that means for CLI tools and
I'll give it I'll have an example here
in a second is yeah again so these are
run with python for the most part all
wrapped around Python
and facilitate getting the data in say
to something like AWS batch or some
other sort of like short-term data
processing infrastructure
executing the job and then moving the
data back out so it can be used for
further analysis
a few examples of these tools so uh
blast is an incredibly popular tool for
doing searches uh the the basic idea is
you have some Library basically a
database of sequences either DNA or
amino acids you index them in the very
same way you would imagine like indexing
a database and then you search that
index for sequences which align locally
so some like small parts or multiple
parts of say one amino acid sequence
that you care about say cas9
that has a good alignment with your
library and then that is like a hit
basically or you might say uh you know I
found 10 hits in my blast database that
look a lot like cas9
um then uh like my job for example was
often to say okay smart scientist who
has a PHD who knows a lot more about
meat in the field like you take this
subset of sequences and you know use
your subject matter expertise to then
like further Shepherd it along the
pipeline right so a lot of these things
are basically taking something on the
order of of billions moving down to
Millions thousands and something that
that a human human can work with bow tie
is another tool that's used a lot for
aligning short reads back to a reference
so
um
what what happens a lot uh say for like
human genomics is there are these
reference genomes hg38 is is a common
one although people might have seen in
the news
um that we've recently sort of done
um sort of end-to-end
um sequencing of of the genome and so
have a complete genome for for whatever
that means but when you're doing
sequencing the the idea is basically you
break up all the DNA into really smart
small pieces and then you try to align
those small pieces back to a reference
and bow tie can help there and then Sam
tools is is a a set of tools actually if
we're working with those alignments or
merging them or visualizing them to try
to get an understanding of how well did
those sequences that you broke up like
align back to to the reference so just a
couple examples of like how CLI tools
are used and these are all sort of
available as clis not python
um I think everybody in this room loves
python python is is basically just not
fast enough for these tasks given the
amount of data that has to be processed
so for the most part they're written in
C or C plus plus or nowadays you know
rust is obviously the um the language du
jour for
um for fast compiled languages
um
so yeah so those uh tools aren't
developed by folks like me they are used
by folks like me to build larger
pipelines for some business use case and
so what that means as it comes to AWS
and how it comes to
um to python is you know the
productionalization if you will although
that's that's sort of a grandiose term
for what goes on but you know basically
it's kind of wrapping these tools going
through the uh the devops challenges if
you will to containerize them or to get
them to a point where they can be
deployed in the cloud
um you know either I use AWS quite a bit
but but Azure is certainly capable as
well uh you know have to say that since
we're here
um but yeah so
um and it's important because these
tools need to be sort of either
vertically scaled so you know we're
talking like
um say like a quarter terabyte of Ram or
you know 32 to 64 CPUs or uh distribute
them and scale them horizontally say you
know
um 20 30 40 machines kind of running at
the same time and so these tools have
really been a boon for industry
um and for uh for finance more or less
because you don't have to make the large
Capital outlays to buy a cluster which
for the most part are only available at
research institutions or you know if say
say Microsoft or other very very large
organizations
um to give you a little bit of sense of
like what these tools look like or what
these pipelines look like this is taken
from
um nfcor which is a next flow which is
kind of as a company and a tool uh built
around
um
these pipelines and building sort of
reproducible pipelines and so every one
of these little nodes is like a step in
the process so uh cat fastq for example
the very first node is you're more or
less like printing the fastq sub
sampling the fastq
um and sorry to take a step back a fastq
file is a specific bioinformatic format
for sequencing reads so it has the ID of
the read the individual say like atcs
and G's associated with that read and
quality scores that try to confer how
high a quality the read is
I don't know if anybody watched the unit
talk earlier today but some of those
types of models are used in what's
called base calling which is you know
you don't necessarily like you sort of
take for granted that there's some
sequence but really you somehow have to
figure out and literally call that that
base say an a is an A or is a t or
whatever whatever it is and the
technology behind those are are really
what goes on in sequencers say like a
company called Illumina is is a a big
player there particularly for short read
sequences or what's actually been coming
about uh more recently are tools called
or techniques and Technologies called
long read sequences which are very
exciting because they allow much larger
reads so it's much easier to say a line
um say a thousand base pairs or get
resolution to where a thousand base
pairs align back to a reference genome
than 60 base pairs and how that might
align back to a genome so
um yeah just uh I guess this slide jerk
is trying to be a little scary in some
perspective but uh it's really it's
really not that bad
um okay so what does that look like for
python one of these nodes might be say a
batch job
um I hope that's
okay yeah it's not too bad
um so this is kind of what it looks like
I mean this is not not great code but
you can just sort of Imagine where say
we might use uh sub processors just a
library in the python standard Library
CSV and temp file and then say Bodo 3
which is uh the popular python library
for working with AWS services
this blast command the um the command on
line eight is what's actually calling
blast P so blast p is a protein search
and it's running a query so Dash query
on some input fast a file a fast day
file is analogous to a fastq file except
it doesn't have the quality score it's
more you're considering that you just
have good resolution and confidence in
the sequence and so we're querying this
input sequence the dash DB is the
database I mentioned in this case NR is
sort of a shorthand for a non-redundant
database
lots of sequences and like due to
Evolution are very similar lots of
proteins are very similar because they
carry out similar tasks and so they have
similar structures and often have
similar
amino acid sequences you're then getting
the output that's like the dash out fmt
in in six which is uh you know always
great because then you have to sort of
dive into the documentation to say what
does that mean in this case it's more or
less a CSV so it's it's relatively easy
to work with
um
yeah then we're sort of running the job
and that's line sort of 12 through 18
where we're opening up a temporary file
running the blast command outputting it
to to the temp file and then sort of
going through the munging tasks to put
it into a CSV and ultimately upload it
to S3 so
um you know it's not like the super cool
like algorithm development but mostly
just the glue code which is oftentimes
the valuable stuff or at least you know
sort of table Stakes to the valuable
stuff of getting the data from the
output into the hands of the scientists
so they can they can use it
um
okay so I just look under time okay
great
um yeah so a couple things
um I'll just just kind of mention
um the challenges in in this space
um one a lot of the software that is uh
developed uh like I mentioned is in uh
compiled languages say like C C plus
plus
Etc and so managing the dependencies and
getting those to run on different
Hardware is is a challenge I know this
in particularly particularly well
because where true Technologies has uh C
plus plus software that we try to
develop and serve to end users which
mean targeting lots of different
architectures and that's uh comes sort
of a can be a devops headache
um I think the last talk in here was
from uh uh individual sort of anaconda
that has been a huge Boon to folks in
the bioinformatics space due to its
ability to take complex to build
dependencies uh bottle them up and make
them basically a conda install away so
so conda is really good there and then
of course being able to containerize
these workflows inside of Docker and
then you can just sort of ship your
container to whatever cloud provider
you're using
also scaling these CLI tools like I
mentioned is particularly important both
vertically and horizontally
sometimes these indexes like I mentioned
which are sort of like the index of a
database can be you know a need to be
loaded into memory and B can be sort of
uh you know on the orders of two to
three hundred
Mega gigabytes in size excuse me
um and so yeah like relatively large
machines are needed or given the amount
of sequences you're trying to search
just trying to go through that on one
machine even if it's big is going to
take take a really long time so it's
pretty important to be able to
find ways to scale these again both up
and and out
okay so that's that's sort of one area
in which you see Python and
bioinformatics quite a bit excuse me
which is
um
yeah just this sort of like cloud
containerization and you know
productionization if you will of of
tools
okay
so now moving on to one of the
um uh you know popular areas both sort
of generally and in bioinformatics are
sort of like the application of large
language models
um like I mentioned
um it's very much sort of focused around
next token prediction and and that's the
generation of foundational language
models so I guess if uh to take a step
back uh folks are familiar with like
chat GPT like chat gbt
uses a language model under the hood but
it's sort of fine-tuned to be able to do
dialogue well right so it's not just we
just like take the output of some next
token prediction and like great you have
a model that works really well for
dialogue you have a large language model
generating a foundation this sort of
foundation for some fine tuning which
takes you to the application that you're
that you're interested in that same idea
is applied here where we're going to
take and and not not me but I'll I'll
talk about a model that does this but
again just sort of does next token
prediction to try to get
um you know at like the protein in this
if you will much like where uh llms and
NLP are learning sort of the statistical
distribution of language and then
building on that these models are trying
to learn the sort of distribution of
um you know Evolution for more or less
and that's what we have here and this is
pretty small so I'll just kind of try to
give some sense of what's going on but
what we're looking at is the esm2 model
this is the inference model esm2 is
stands for evolutionary evolutionary
scale model it was released by meta
um a cup maybe like a couple years ago
although they've done a couple versions
since then and if you look at this you
know it looks very very similar to what
you might see if you're working with
some other large language model some
other Transformer based model you know
so we're basically getting like the
model and the alphabet so again folks
who are familiar with NLP you might have
some sort of Corpus you might do some
tokenization on that Corpus then you
have your your vocabulary
thankfully in in biology the vocabulary
or the alphabet if you will is much more
constrained it depends a little bit on
how you do the tokenization uh of course
but um for say proteins you're looking
at you know 20 22 amino acids kind of
depending on what um
uh well like which what you consider
amino acid but at the end of the day
those are quite small you might sort of
break these up into cameras which is
really uh common so say like a camera of
size three or six or whatever but at the
end of the day yeah you have this set of
data which we see kind of Midway through
like protein one protein two and so
forth
um you're you're basically sort of
running this through the model which is
what you see sort of like the with torch
no grad context manager you're getting
the results and then you're getting sort
of these representations right and so so
that's where you're getting the
embedding of your model
um which you hope to then be able to use
in the sense uh or in some Downstream
task
um and I'll talk about a couple a couple
approaches or a couple use cases there
um where one a couple use cases for
those embeddings one is sort of protein
similarity search so blast is an amazing
Tool uh it's been around for ages uh it
has probably the best recall of any tool
out there
but ultimately it's it's
[Music]
um
it's a bit slow and can be a bit
cumbersome and requires a lot of work to
both generate the database to search and
execution and you would like to be able
to say potentially have a simpler tool
that rather than running the alignment
between two sequences to generate the
local alignment to then score you might
want to say run the cosine similarity
right that's a pretty easy task it can
be done pretty quickly and so that is
kind of like a direct translation if you
will where yeah you have like sentence
embeddings how similar are these two
sentences how similar are these two
words how similar are these two
documents
same idea how similar are these two
proteins based on the similarity of
their embeddings and there's where you
sort of Hope the esm model and the
embeddings can can work yeah similarity
you can like or similarly excuse me like
protein protein interaction models are
really common uh or one one application
or sort of metagenomic
metagenomic analysis is is another one
so
um
say you went to you know some
far-reaching um a location on Earth took
a big soil sample so uh when I was at
zymergen this was a really common thing
where you basically send out a team they
take a soil sample you sequence it you
try to see is there if there's anything
interesting that could be potentially
used for say like novel antibiotics
before you can do any of that you have
to figure out kind of what's in that
sample and like I mentioned earlier
um lots of proteins are pretty similar
because they carry similar functions
like you know and so
um
yeah being able to use something like an
esm embedding or these other tools can
help you determine proteins or other
sort of like taxonomies or other things
like in your sample without necessarily
having
um
uh or yeah well I should say to
hopefully do better than we can now this
is where I get it a little bit that it's
still a bit nascent because oftentimes
we still fall back to some of the older
tools
which is a little bit disappointing but
I am hopeful at some point that we can
we can move on to to these models
um
so just to show this is kind of a fancy
picture this is a pretty picture
um this is the esm metagenomic Atlas so
uh what Facebook did or medic excuse me
is basically they train this model on
tons of proteins and then they embedded
those proteins using the SM model
projected it down into a 2d space and
then so if you go to
esmatlas.com it will pull this up and
you can sort of like pull your drag your
mouse over this embedding picture and
you can look at the protein structures
and unsurprisingly
proteins which are near in the embedding
space tend to have similar structure
right so that's sort of like the hope
and the goal and that that turns out to
be the case
um yeah so those are some information
retrieval tasks and those are often
again just done by generating the
embeddings coming up with some
similarity score and then trying to use
that
um
yeah and then I'll I'll just mention uh
predictive tasks uh much in the same way
as we talked a little bit about sort of
fine-tuning these foundational
foundational NLP models
um the goal and the hope is to be able
to fine-tune some of these llm models
for other tasks so
um if you do have training data or you
do have sort of like experimental data
you hope you would hope to be able to
say okay can I say predict like the
enzymatic activity of some protein using
the embeddings as the features
um it's you know it's extremely
challenging to do this in biology
because the data is often like not great
more or less there's like large amounts
of bias in the data batch effects uh
reasons why some set of data might not
be very good and so you know not to use
the sort of banal like garbage in
garbage out but that really yeah I mean
it is it is certainly a truism and
makes predictive tasks while
um nascent
um still unfortunately like not not
quite there
um okay yeah like I mentioned I'll just
I'll just go through these quickly uh
yeah data availability and quality is is
a huge challenge
um because the data uh quality is not
great uh and the data availability is
also not great because a lot of the
biotech companies are not uh you know
very keen to release their data and so
the amount of data that you have
available to potentially fine-tune a
model is is pretty small uh you know
Fair a lot of these biotech companies
they're IP and their
um like that like say some some protein
that they patented that is their company
and so they're very uh hesitant to to
release that interpretability
explainability
um you know same thing I'm sure everyone
has heard in in all areas of machine
learning definitely applies here it
certainly applies when you're trying to
talk to a scientist and telling them
like this is what I think you should do
these are the candidates I think you
should progress to the next round and if
it is a black box you're you're not
going to get very very far
um yep again overfitting uh
generalization generally a challenge of
course with Biology it is computational
resources also a big challenge you know
these like the number of uh of proteins
in these very large data sets is very
very large
um and so being able to train models and
learn learn if you will all in those is
is a non non-trivial task
um yeah and then
um you know if you were able to discover
drugs would you like necessarily want to
apply them we've also seen some
applications recently there's a
researcher named Andrew White
um he just released his group just
released a paper and they actually
censored some of the data because there
were some concerns about the llms being
used to generate potentially like toxic
drugs and like sort of poisonous drugs
or flammable or flammable uh compounds
excuse me so
um
it's it's a little bit it's always
tricky and you should always sort of
think about what are the ethical
considerations it's uh another level of
trickiness when you have to consider
that like you could do like physical
harm to an individual
um with uh with releasing them or you
know greatly lower the barrier to how
hard you would have to work to make a
compound which has
um uh nefarious intent
um cool so I'll just go through this
quickly so I'm a little bit behind and
those are 30 minutes
um yeah again it's very exciting but it
is very nascent uh um for the reasons I
mentioned so I'm hopeful
um I I follow I follow the field follow
the the advancements that are happening
um unfortunately like it's just not
something that you sort of
um see outside of maybe companies you
know trying to raise money on
um on on hopes and dreams
so so that's the really cool stuff llms
um to go to the like the you know the
other side of things which is just like
good old-fashioned data munging
um bioinformatic data is uh challenging
to deal with both because of the file
formats or very idiosyncratic like I've
mentioned already
um and uh the sort of tasks that you
have to do do can be challenging so I'll
talk about biopython which is uh
probably the most common library for
working with bioinformatic data in
Python and then I'll talk I'll give an
example quickly of pie ranges which is a
specific Library helping to deal again
with with genomic ranges
um
so biopython has a bunch of tools
um both for like the analysis what we'll
talk about here in a second is the
um the file formatting so I talked about
fast day files
um already and what we'll see here is
like this is a genbank file which you
you see on the right and
part of the genbank file
I don't even know if it's a
specification per se but like white
space like helps Define the format to
give you a sense of like how sort of
tricky it is to deal with this this file
like literally so you can have if you
have lines which are too long that can
cause problems in parsing the underlying
data moreover you sort of see like
features so um in the lower left under
genbank parsing what you see there is a
stretch of of DNA that is what's called
a biosynthetic gene cluster and this is
responsible for like the production of
natural products or more nowadays more
known as secondary metabolites
antibacterial compounds and the like and
so the stretch of DNA has several
features on it and each one of these
features is sort of defined in a little
blurb where you say say the very the
second to bottom one is like an mRNA
from position uh
5170 to
6387 right and so like these are
features on the underlying DNA and if
you want to do something with this data
basically you got to get it out of this
format and that's where something like
biopython comes in
and you can see an example here where we
can use biopython and it's got this
great seek IO pack or module that can
help you read the genbank file parse it
and turn it into a CSV which could be
suitable for for other work so
um
yep if you if you know any bioinformed
editions or anybody who works in the
field ask them about genbank files and
they will probably shutter
um a bit and unfortunately uh like
biopython sort of excuse me uh is
basically the only good genbank parser
at least that I'm that I'm aware of
um
another one quickly is is pi ranges so
like I mentioned
um pie ranges and doing analysis on
ranges is a very common task so say we
have feature a uh which is you know some
stretch of DNA say say RNA or the start
of the gene say feature B is maybe like
the transcription start site you might
want to take the overlap and figure out
okay what part on the genome is both the
the start of the Gene and the
transcription initiation happen and
that's an overlap right so so pretty
pretty simple idea pie ranges have some
like beautiful utilities to make that
happen
um so what we're looking at here is say
again you know some feature a some
feature B feature a is from a thousand
to two thousand feature B is 1500 to
2500 you can join those kind of like in
a database join if you will on those and
say and it will overlap and so you can
imagine having many features and trying
to join those together and this can give
you some sense of
um
uh oh yeah which which uh features
overlap with which other features so
um we're sort of joining feature B onto
feature a and so we see on the right
side the start of B and the end is B um
and then start and end our our feature a
um here's a much more complex example
where
um we're sort of taking uh the cpg is um
is like a very important site these are
like sections of the genome that are um
that are rich for C's and G's
um you're essentially joining those on
exons you're then sort of subsetting
those where like a feature
um or where they're say more than 30
cpgs in that area you're sorting them
formatting them subsetting them Etc like
not to walk through all this but you can
sort of see like the complex data
munching manipulations that that you
might want to do to summarize this data
and summarize for what you're looking at
in the genome because again like you
have to sort of think about what the
underlying data is which is just you
know stretches of sequences and features
on top of those but
as sort of us being dumb humans we need
to kind of turn those into tables that
we can work with and so Pi ranges is a
popular library for for doing just that
[Music]
um
okay so yeah so uh some some challenges
limitations for for data munging
um
yeah again python is just unfortunately
um uh slow there are lots of great
libraries uh out there for making it
faster
um but at the end of the day
um it's um
yeah it's often useful just to write the
thing in C plus plus or rust a lot of
the the tools that where true for
example rights are either in a c plus or
rust to to improve performance
um
standardization of bioinformatics
formats is is very challenging like I
mentioned like having white space sort
of determine like the how the file looks
and how the file is parsed makes it very
challenging
um some of the reproducibility like I
mentioned at the very beginning also
rears its head here which is like
um
yeah pie ranges for example is not super
easy to install depending on your
underlying python package and so that
reproducibility those reproducibility
challenges make analysis hard and so I
sort of wish wish it wasn't as as much
as the Wild Wild West as as it is but
but it definitely is not um
yeah it's not not to say it's in a bad
State and I would encourage you all if
you are interested in the field uh I
actually don't have my background in
bioinformatics I sort of come out of a
recommendation uh a system uh before
before getting the opportunity to join a
company and sort of love it and I think
it's it's great
um but
um yeah it's not like you're working
with click stream for example if you're
if you're familiar with click streamer
or those sorts of things it's definitely
um yeah more challenging and more
challenging than that well that's
challenging for different reasons than
this but I really enjoy this so
um
so yeah so I think uh I'll just kind of
quickly wrap up
um and yeah so so thanks everybody for
for your attention you know we talked a
little bit about sort of like taking
python using python to scale up tools
and how we can take that uh python to
productionized CLI tools talked a little
bit about sort of the invo llms and kind
of where they are and how they're
applied currently to two bioinformatics
and then of course just like the lower
level Less Fun Less Fun data munging
um yeah and so with that I'll just
thanks thanks everyone for your time
foreign
uh yeah yeah so
um
like I I don't remember so like esm for
so sorry the question is sort of like
what are we talking in terms of data
sizes
um and so like esm I think was trained
in order of like 500 billion sequences
where those sequences are
um
um like one amino acid and that amino
acid could be anywhere from like or that
protein could be anywhere from like 100
to a thousand uh amino acids so
um not huge not say like uh common crawl
or something like that but certainly not
um not similar
any more question
I guess thank you yep
thanks everybody
[Applause]